ready
okay okay
[Music]
I love the Green Day When I was in
elementary school
that's Blink 182 Sam it's not Green Day
I think we all knew gosh no your know
your bands dude no you're no your late
90s punk bands late 90s more like 2022
comeback Revival yeah I heard about that
and I I kind of felt ashamed
for them
for them or yeah keep going I know I
really can't speak I mean I mean
Christian knows all about getting what
it's like to get tickets tickets for uh
like a modern an actual like big band
concert yeah it's expensive right
I know I I still I haven't paid more
than like 40 bucks for a concert ticket
so I feel like a reasonable rate but you
know Ticketmaster and all that stuff
that's been happening lately yeah
400 a ticket I don't know man I I don't
think I would want to season 82 today
stadiums aren't getting any bigger
regardless of the cost
I I don't think I would want to see them
perform today like at all like even if
the tickets are free
I mean I guess if they like showed up at
a party you were at and they put on a
concert
you'd be like oh this is pretty cool you
know it's like dope yeah
I wouldn't pay a hundred bucks to go see
him at Staples Center or whatever that's
a deal right
a hundred dollars is like a deal these
days what's this uh what's My Age Again
you know that song uh where there's a
line is like
23 like I turned 23 or whatever that
song Turned 23 like last month yeah
that's crazy
yeah because that's exactly why I
wouldn't go see him
old you know it's like Let It live let
it live in Nostalgia you know for like
the time and the place in which it was
popularized and not
you know I just don't go to concerts not
that I actively dislike concerts I just
never get around to doing them I'd
rather go away most of the time that
would be like that would be like if we
like reshot and remastered one of our
old YouTube videos and then then
re-released it it's like actually I
think that's a great idea
we kind of did that with a glitch a
little bit that's fine yeah but that was
kind of a that was for funsies you know
that was like let's see what Peter can
do with it laughs
well we gotta we got a week here yeah
we've had a few weeks hot week
end of the year well there's I think
there's a few things worth talking about
first off yeah
um
I'd like to hear still a little more
about your travels
well I I got to the studio today and I'm
about to go home from the studio today
travels am I right you went to the you
you visited Jake's Homeland yeah so okay
uh
my home state yeah so I guess a week and
a half ago the weekend before
Thanksgiving uh I and Christian we flew
to Dallas we were there for less than 24
hours we got there like Friday night and
we left Saturday evening and the
reasoning for that is because we were
doing uh some client work client work
which is something you almost never do
unless it's a really good opportunity
and this opportunity involved creating
some neural Radiance field scans of
which I just made a whole video about
like that same weekend Nerf uh Nerfs
yeah exactly and so we got to work with
Luka doncic who is an MVP MBA player
basically he's one of the best NBA
players this year uh and has been for a
few years now he's a pretty young player
he's like 23 years old
um
Slovenia yes oh my God you're right
that was a reference
you're a quarter Slovenian yeah my dad
was half damn really I didn't know that
wow yep yeah so yeah uh we had an hour
of Lucas time this is through his
production company they were doing a
brand integration with Nerf and they
thought it'd be a fun thing to do a Nerf
Nerf
so basically I had an hour of his time
and I just
stood him in a few different positions
told him to be incredibly still and I
scanned him I worked with his dad Sasha
as well and his trainer Marco really
cool people at one point all three of
them were just surrounding me and
talking in Slovenian but they're all
like six and a half feet or taller
they're all massive they're like massive
they're like Hill Giants
his dad uh Sasha doncic is like a
literal bear he's like six foot eight I
think and like he literally looks like
what a bear would look like if they
stood up on their hind legs it's crazy
because he got escorted into the gym by
a couple of other guys and I can clearly
see his collarbone above the other two
guys who are directly in front of him it
was crazy yeah so that was a really cool
opportunity and so
uh my last week or so week and a half
has just been nothing but working on
that nothing but net dude but that's
that's opened up this whole like thing
for me anyways like a like it was very
eye-opening because I was like okay so
obviously you know
Nerfs they're super dope it's it's it's
not like surprising that they want to
like do something cool with that not to
mention I guess there's like a NERF
tie-in with it which is the joke yeah so
there's like Nerf guns in it so that's
that's funny but then there's blasters
Sam sir Nerf blaster fire rounds well
that's fine that's what I tell Gideon
too I I just like just say Blaster just
don't don't run around saying I'm gonna
shoot you with my gun right now
oh no but uh no but so I was going
through uh his his Tick Tock and you
know social media it's all client work
pretty much I mean except for uh it's
funny there's a bunch of stuff that
they've been posting that involves a
bunch of very Advanced like visual
effects stuff like they have a whole
meta-human case it made a human on him
and then they're deepaking his face onto
the made of human which we've that's
been around for you know a few months
now or like basically this year people's
got you know uh Keen to doing that
but they're doing that so he doesn't
have to make he doesn't want he doesn't
want it I don't want to speak too much
on his behalf yeah and whatnot but like
his main focus is winning the NBA yeah
yeah of course of course that's all he
wants to focus on but he has a
production company he understands uh the
need to sort of build this sort of nest
egg that can carry him through into
retirement and whatnot and so a hot Tick
Tock page I mean basically that's the
boy that's the that's going to be the
thing that makes him the money Millions
I am sure I am not like sure of course
communicating this properly but
basically he doesn't really want to do
filming stuff like yeah it's a whole
ordinance doesn't want to be in a big
like group situation it's kind of
awkward I can move and disapprove of
things and then there's like someone has
to direct it and film it and like you're
always yeah I mean what we do here he
kind of just doesn't mind the idea of
someone else
having him review trick shots and
whatnot using deep fakes of making him
do that it's insane I and the opposite I
would actively want that to not be the
case unless I was the one making it but
I get it from his perspective he's like
I I don't want to have to do this stuff
but I kind of have to do this stuff yeah
everyone's saying what are you doing you
don't want to like post on social media
all the time and have that consume your
life and he's like no I won't I won't
play I want to play b-ball they were
saying I'm a baller guys they've been
seeing a lot of people
success on on their social media just
from when he just started being active
like on Tick Tock like an interviewer
would be like
uh what was the question like what's
your favorite scary movie and he's like
oh one through five I liked them all
I was like okay that was actually really
funny
the weird thing about the weird thing
about
um what he's doing
is when we when we started the uh zero
Vega account
it was it was kind of like a parody of
something that we thought might happen
in the future yeah and this kind of
what's happening is happening exactly
that yeah it's this is like something
out of like
some what what are those all those
Jennifer Lawrence movies uh people are
gonna slay me Hunger Games Yes The
Hunger Games yeah
um so so but you know how it's like this
weird like weird future dystopia and
there's like people
yeah you know and I mean you're exactly
right it's what we've talked about I'm
an even Blade Runner you can just like
yeah
this guy gets this guy gets paid
millions of dollars to play basketball
and then he's created this social media
accounts with out that he's not actually
in but like he's in but he's not in
using just on those specific
experimental technology yeah I mean yeah
but it's it's it was surprising also to
me like how in touch they are with
what's coming out
yeah yeah
did you talk to him about that did you
ask him like why do how do you even know
about this I didn't really talk to him
that much I asked him how he was feeling
he's like tired because the night before
he had literally just gotten his 50th
triple double which is where you get uh
double digits in both uh scoring
rebounds and passes it says sports ball
it's where you get double digits in
three different sports balls yeah yeah
exactly three things yeah and and he did
it in a very very short amount of time
like record-breaking short amount of
time he was the second fastest to get to
50 in the league history he beat out
Magic Johnson by a single game
um to get to second place anyway point
being he had a hell of a game the night
before which we caught the tail end of
in a bar uh shout out to the bartender
in Dallas by the way you made our night
great uh he recognized this and got our
uh compt our dinner
anyway
um
yeah and so we worked with uh Luca the
next day and you know he was tired he
had just spent the entire morning
training and whatnot and he had an hour
of free time to come get some scans with
me and uh he I don't think cares too
much about everything going on I guess
is what I'm saying it's his production
team and his manager who are very tapped
into stuff yeah his manager is a she's
pretty cool she was previously the
manager for Dirk Nowitzki I guess still
the manager agent if you will one of
those like power people when like she
walked in the room you were instant like
oh yeah she's the one in charge she's re
gold
yeah she's Eric she's Ariel Ariel gold
but like even she understood like what a
mesh was and stuff like that you know
really and like the production team they
they I don't know how they they knew
about Nerfs as this new thing and
whatnot but they're pretty tapped into
the Zeitgeist as we we like to say and
somehow my name got like floated up to
the top of that and they wanted
specifically me to be the point man
interacting with Luca to get to not only
like get the scans but to like make him
feel less awkward about it because which
I I thought was very cool that's awesome
very proud of that um well the first one
really went really well
the first one slash kind of the second
one yeah whatever the joys of clients
client work is it's one of those things
where uh I I do client work so
infrequently now that I forget that at
the end of the day even if what you made
is super dope if it's not what they
wanted it doesn't matter yeah and so I
had basically pulled an all-nighter uh
because that was the thing we shot on
Tuesday and our first deliverable was
Tuesday
Saturday to Tuesday
and so on Saturday
correct yeah yeah Sean Saturday
I I did like I did a few hours worth of
work on Sunday and then a bunch of work
all day Monday almost pulled an online
or getting this thing done and I was
super happy with it super pleased
submitted it and they're like yeah this
isn't gonna work at all and I'm like oh
no and they listed off a bunch of very
valid reasons Luca and the Blaster were
like a little too blurry
um and I started like a little too far
away some stuff I was like okay so I had
to Pivot and make a completely new thing
that ended up taking more time so I was
I basically pulled two back-to-back
all-nighters to finish up that one first
post that is now on Lucas uh but because
Instagram because it's sweet I'm pretty
proud of it I went into it yeah with the
expectation that all right if the mirror
World type thing that I was trying to
get didn't work out we have the backup
which is do a scan of him with a bunch
of red lights do another scan of him
with a bunch of blue lights in the
roughly the same position I could do the
same camera move through both and just
cut back and forth between the scans
I think one thing people don't
understand though about what you're
talking about is when you just say I'm
just going to reframe it
you can do that you can pick an entirely
different camera move from the scan a
lot of people don't you know we're so
ingrained with this idea that you know
what you get in camera what you get in
the frame is what you have to work with
unless you have another shot I mean
you're totally right but this is really
cutting edge in the sense that not only
does it give you a much higher quality
and faster scan than photogrammetry but
you can just like photogrammetry but
more so you can pick your shots and move
through the space however you want the
camera to move yeah I think so like for
any of you confused listening or
watching right now confused about what
it is we're talking about with Nerfs and
whatnot we're not talking about the
blasters even though we kind of are
right now we're talking about the video
you should have watched yeah if you're
confusing the channel you should check
it out now it's like I forget what the
title is like nerves we'll wait
it's in the description check it out
click that link in the description
um it'll tell you everything you could
possibly want to know about Nerfs and
why they're a big deal but basically to
summarize if you already are familiar
with photogrammetry that kicks out like
a 3D model and you use that for things
whereas this is kind of the same process
but instead of kicking out a 3D model it
uses a neural render kind of like the
same type of rendering that makes deep
fix and it just renders out a Viewpoint
from anywhere within that volume or
around that object and so it creates
this sort of it's a very similar things
photogrammetry but the perspective on it
is completely different because now
you're actually getting what seems to
look like footage the quality is still
not quite there yet it's blurry low like
the Fidelity isn't that high but
ultimately it's like it's it because
it's not trying to reconstruct a texture
or a model it's able to figure out all
the different qualities of all the
materials yeah and you see all the
actual like lighting reflection that was
there yeah it's so it's not really cool
it's absolutely nuts yes I'm
capitalizing on like a subtle way of how
light works and and the result is
something that actually looks very
realistic yeah only two weeks away from
being higher quality yeah I mean
probably yeah
every single uh Nerf that I've made so
far I've run through topaz upscale and
I've denoised it at a hundred percent
like maximizing the the denoising gets
rid of a lot of the weird artifacts you
see in these Nerfs along with that
special sharpening
we're using it to upgrade a bunch of
website assets oh nice okay yeah I've
been using it like crazy the last few
weeks on these videos yeah well there's
like these 10 year old videos that have
these 380p thumbnails and so we're up
we're just using topaz to upgrade them
all that's awesome crazy yeah yeah no
but this was like so like
it's a crazy week because like
the Nerf stuff is insane and then also
like when it comes to like uh other AI
image environment stuff like so we're
working on the anime
rock paper scissors video has that been
announced it
yeah
rock paper scissors
we have the previous anime videos like
anime fidget spinner Etc but so this one
we're doing another one and Nico has
been messing with stable diffusion to
turn footage and images into an anime
style so we still get to basically film
it live action but then use it's
basically just using stable diffusion to
apply a fancy anime filter to everything
um and there's you know some whatever
some that doesn't quite do it justice
though Sam there's some finer details
but what you just said boils it down
Waters it down so much yeah but but the
thing is is that it like but that's also
the kind of the Epiphany that's coming
out of this which is like everyone's
like oh my gosh AI image generation art
blah blah but it's like
it's a filter bro yeah it's like just to
feel like like forgetting all like the
crazy like mind-blowing AI stuff it's
like really it's just a filter well the
way you're using it is a filter because
you're doing the image to image type
stuff yeah we're basically yeah Nico's
taking like a still frame of someone on
a green screen and then
basically makes it look anime
um but then so like we were talking
about this I showed you this Earl this
morning yeah and then Fender too but um
it's the idea of like okay well now what
about the background so you have a
footage of a character so how do you do
the backgrounds and like I was like
initially a first gonna like maybe see
if I could just use like mid-journey or
something to make some cool backgrounds
but then like I made one image and then
realized oh shoot this isn't gonna work
because every image is gonna be
different yeah yeah there's no
consistency like how do you do that so I
was like okay well he's using image
image for the footage
so why not just use like a 3D
environment like and then apply image to
image to that to then now keep
consistency so that way when the shot
reverse shot punch in zoom out it's like
all like consistent in the same space
yeah you basically have your set yeah
you can make look like and you're just
sourcing that in unreal like so yeah I
literally just I go into the marketplace
Gothic interior Cathedral get a sweet
thing and then boom I like all yesterday
and today it's just okay there's a
couple steps in between though that you
that you really quickly glazed over
which is number one for this they unlike
the spider-verse piece that you guys
have taken and created your own data set
from which the the the texture is being
created well that's that's not that's
for the characters for the character
yeah that's for the characters but then
also for the environments so now now not
only do we have at fully animated
characters with their own data sets that
we're not using like a data set that's
already created from but we're creating
our own data set and then second of all
what Sam is saying you basically when he
says you basically just create a 3D
environment what you're doing is you're
you're going into unreal you're you're
creating an environment but then when
you when the
when stable diffusion spits you back
each individual image all the images are
consistent because it has a consistent
thing to reference well it's actually
even simple it is actually simpler than
that first off I don't create the
environment I bought it well okay yeah
and I I had to do very little work to
basically clean it up and re-light it
didn't even like do anything for the
render you just like point to the camera
and you're like screenshot are you like
I'm not even rendering a frame I
literally am just using their screenshot
tool in unreal because it's faster and
then like when I'm actually when I'm
processing the backgrounds I'm not even
using a special lead like it's not even
a special trained model really it's just
the right prompt saying 90s anime film
and then a couple like you know anime
references and stuff like that and then
boom it just Anime filter so and the
thing is is that unlike Nico like he you
know they're focused on the footage
which is moving so they're you know
focused on the temporal consistency
basically how much does this image
change based off of each frame but for
the background work like if you think
about animated films it's 2D so I don't
have to worry about that at all like
because we're just gonna stack up you
know 2D elements and hand animate them
just kind of like you would have an
actual anime piece before Anime got into
3D and all all that stuff yeah so
I technically have it a little bit
easier uh basically moral of this story
is that it's a fascinating new workflow
that could potentially reduce the amount
of effort and time required to make a
full-on anime show but there are some
downsides that we're exploring and
discovering as well uh the one thing you
mentioned Sam is that and because that
was the first thing I saw too is that I
I can't quite shake the feeling that it
just looks like a rotoscoped video yep
there's a yeah so that's that's a thing
there it's like if you just play the
video with the filter on it like of a
person it just kind of looks like a
person with like a yeah rotoscope colors
on them reminds me of that Lord of the
Rings cartoon that came out like 30 40
years ago
yeah well but they've been doing that
for a long time that like they've since
day one like Disney films like like
Cinderella and Snow White or whatever
that was like they film reference
footage and then Trace that right as
they're like bass animation so it's like
that's a core Foundation of you know
animation yeah I guess I just wonder
like what are the ways that we can like
push this further so it doesn't quite
just look like a filter over video
because that was what made the the
stable diffusion stuff really cool like
shooting uh you know Dean in the
Spider-Man outfit on a green screen uh
but transforming the entire suit into
the actual like yeah uh Peter Parker
suit and and make it Tom Holland and all
that stuff I think it's all just frame
rate stuff yeah it's like just taking
like we were talking today about
essentially forcing ourselves to be
limited to the tech they'd be using for
like a 1995 anime film so it's like
you're not doing 3D camera moves you're
like being like okay you know what
everything's animated on twos maybe the
K There's an actual like camera moving
like with different cells and stuff that
can be 24 frames per second just like
trying to take all the like all of the
aspects that make that anime look and
try to do that like where it's like
maybe a character goes to a pose and
then they're just stuck in that pose for
like yeah I guess what I'm getting at is
like how do we make Nico look like
something more rather than just like oh
yeah that's cartoon Nico so because
that's the tough thing which is that's
the trade-off like if you want the
temporal consistency like if you want
each frame to look look more like the
last one you kind of have to turn the
style down a tiny bit right because if
it if it's gonna go anime filter and big
eyes like because your eyes aren't big
so it has to guess every frame now yeah
where those big eyes are gonna be and
what this shape is going to be versus
when if you tone that down a tiny bit
it's able to actually look at the
footage and say that's where the eye is
that's how big it is yeah what if we
used
um what if in the future we used special
effects makeup to accentuate different
angular parts of the face or the eyes or
the teeth yeah oh yeah yeah and I was
thinking about that too like for like
yeah I was telling Nico like we should
do a data set with like we put like fake
scar make up on him or something like
that yeah totally now
he has a cool scar in all the pictures
yeah yeah we were talking it's like once
we shoot all the footage create a new
data set based on that so it
specifically knows how to draw those
exact frames that it like we're actually
feeding it for the final like piece the
final short film yeah so the dish that's
trained on that like the actual actors
in costume specifically for the exact
shots that are in the film so it's like
because basically what you're doing it
when you're training a model is you're
just telling like feeding it images to
be like hey stable diffusion learn how
to draw this so if you're feeding it
exactly what it needs to draw like if
you're feeding at the actual frames that
you want to work on it's going to learn
to draw that basically right so it's
gonna
yeah yeah well there's like a cool
technique too that I remember we we
talked about back in the day with the
Deep fakes which is kind of similar
um which is like doing deep faked makeup
so to speak where you're you're not
necessarily changing someone's identity
but you're applying something to their
face that would be either like time
consuming or cost prohibitive to do for
every shot or something like that yeah
have you guys seen all the news about
Indiana Jones 5 apparently they're doing
some new de-aging deep fake stable
something for dhb they are not really
they're not doing Indiana Jones five oh
yeah yeah I know that's already been
confirmed for a while yeah oh my God
yeah Return of the Christmas put it to
bed son
I even saw like the class it always
happens every year there's a news story
about like how the director or someone
on the team is like we're doing
everything practically he's like adamant
that all of the backgrounds are
practical and they're not doing CG
backgrounds I'm like okay there's so
much VFX already happening on that movie
like it's like we didn't use a single
VFX shot I'm like you suck [ __ ] yes you
did
Harrison Ford's gonna be limping off one
of them trains son yeah I mean it
depends but like you know that's I think
it's once again it's still valid because
the more we like look at like older
practical effects on on the react show
the more I'm starting to realize like
there's this like psychological
distinction that your brain makes when
you see something that's a CG effect
versus something that's practical
because
even when something's like if it's
practical but not necessarily realistic
you still I feel like you still
subconsciously like have a more
like realistic reaction to it and uh you
know and it's like it's because you're
you're you're less believing that it's
not real but how do I say it it's that
tangible feeling you know where it's
like yeah well it's like you actually
existed yeah you know you're watching a
movie yeah so and you're like you know
this isn't real so if something happens
you're like okay obviously that weird
effect isn't real but if it's
practically done then there is this
weird like okay
like that's still despite this all being
fantasy that still happened yeah yeah
and it kind of It kind of helps and
that's that's a hard one to like sort of
evaluate like from a psychology
standpoint because you know the main
argument against that these days is that
for most movies you look at a shot and
it's like is that practical or digital
and people are like oh and it's like
yeah you can't tell like digital effects
these days are so good you can't tell
but at the same time when you can
actually tell that something is real and
not just not suspending your disbelief
there's there's that I don't know
there's something psychological about
knowing that what you're seeing actually
exists in reality yeah rather than was
crafted for the sake of the movie
yeah
yeah and I don't know where the the
value in that lies because at the end of
the day it's all about serving the story
in the movie and
but it's not like it actually practices
it's not like it actually existed in
reality even when it's a special effect
I mean it was particularly done with the
same level of thought process and
insight that a visual effect would be
you're just doing you're just capturing
it all in the frames rather than doing
it
in the frames and later
yeah yeah I think there's always like
there's just
there's a granularity that you get with
practical effects at in a chaotic sort
of seed you can't really replicate
digitally you can get close and whatnot
but you know I I always think back to
what was it War of the Worlds when in
the first part of the movie when the the
tripods start like blowing up the town
and they're getting out of there and
then like he's running down the street
and the houses are blowing up around
them those are all miniature sets that
were being blown up practically so
you're getting all of that chaotic dust
and debris and fragments flying
everywhere that is real and it sells it
a little bit more if they try to do that
digitally you have to then go through
and try to recreate every single one of
those tiny elements it's like you ever
see like the VFX breakdowns of like a
building collapse or something oh yeah
and and it's like oh yeah there's
there's Rubble then there's smaller
Rubble then there's micro rubble and
there's Mega rubble and then there's
dust and then there's thick dust and
there's thin dust and yeah it's like it
goes on and on and on if you actually
want to replicate all of the crazy
things that happen in real life yeah oh
yeah I mean Fenner you've got to know
something or two about those types of
shots I mean how many layers are how
many layers are we talking here too many
how many nodes are we talking it's it
depends man it's like like
some shots it it also just depends on
the render because sometimes I've got
like a CG render and it's like oh it
looks perfect and you just kind of slap
it in Smash the block levels and you're
like awesome and then sometimes you get
something and it's like oh God this
doesn't look good at all and it's you
right it's just so much tweaking and I
mean I'm always of the mindset that it's
like shoot as much as you can
practically and then use VFX to enhance
which I think is like pretty much the
standard take about this sort of thing
yeah yeah but I I was watching a
breakdown on Jurassic world dominion and
they were like you know what we did we
brought back anime animatronic
animatronics dinosaurs well the new
movie they built an animatronic dinosaur
for it and it was this big thing and
it's like the worst looking shots in the
movie It's like because the rest of the
movie is like these like hyper real CG
dinosaurs and they're like but we made
one oh it's the big one for like the big
scene where it's like trying to Chomp
them and stuff yeah like a big
animatronic head yeah but it just looks
kind of jacked up when you're cutting
back to the wall I don't know it's like
when you cut to the wide and it's like
all flexible and yeah and it's like not
being all quick but then it's like
I don't know it's so weird like they're
trying to capture that magic of the
first movie yeah but it felt like they
were doing it as a stunt and I think
that's why it was so good in the
original Jurassic Park is because it was
a necessity to do it that way and
now it's like they're doing it as like
cool so we can say we did practical it's
like the same idea of like we didn't do
any VFX on this movie it's like
well you know it's funny too because
that scene is like you're that's at the
end of the movie yeah and so you've been
watching CG Dinosaurs the whole movie
yeah and now suddenly there's this big
animatronic Chomper yeah the look is
ingrained into your head now in terms of
the story yeah it's so it's so weird
it's on the close-ups too out of all the
shots yeah you know like you pick the
close-up to
yeah I mean I don't know I I'm sure like
I'm sure that animatronic dinosaur they
still did like layers and layers of CG
over top of that where they probably
just like match moved the animatronic
and then but there's something about it
that it just it doesn't work like it
just felt so weird yeah I don't know
it's again it feels like a stunt thing
where it's like
I don't know just doing it because you
can not because it's like gonna make the
film better like Indiana Jones 5 in
Concept in general just doing it because
you can
make the franchise better all his iconic
characters well yeah because he's
probably gonna die after this
in a plane accident at least Jackson
Hole Wyoming
Indiana Jones movies are so good I don't
just first off they're amazing amazing
well the second one the second one is
not which first one is and the third one
is I like Temple Doom out there
nope nope he pulls a man go home I love
that movie it's awesome they're all
awesome all three
it's weird though that they just skipped
the fourth movie and they're just making
an Indiana Jones five
gonna be in it gosh are you trolling
right now no I know this freaking
crystal skulls horrible Indiana Jones
movie was cool or it's just like they're
like kind of jacked up you know they're
like oh we're on a fun adventure and
then there's one or two moments we're
like oh my goodness this is very
disturbing and jacked up like so here's
guys melting and then there's people
like with accelerated aging and turning
into dust and then you have people's
hearts getting ripped out and then like
then they're like all right we're
rebooting it and then like here's a
bunch of like CG monkeys or whatever
here's the thing about it
come on like give me just like the one
like because if you're you're a kid
you're watching it you're like oh it's
well fun adventure movie and there's one
moment you're like oh like you want to
throw up it's so intense you're like oh
my this is so jacked up and then you
walk away going like dude I just watched
the sweetest movie there's this one
jacket part in it you know you're like
that was intense as hell dude yeah
none of the main characters died there's
a part where the guy gets smushed in the
freaking rollers you know this cape
yeah
most things like blood comes out yeah
you know it's like dude this is what
like my parents let me watch this movie
one guy gets eviscerated by an airplane
blade yeah
I'm just saying like
dude you freaking shoots a dude
you've seen the sword fighting she's
sick to fight he shoots a guy and he
became iconic it's just like damn
yeah it's so heavy but but here's here's
what I here's my gripe with these types
of franchise reboots is it's like a lot
of maybe this one will be different some
of them are I'm recognizing that but
most of the time you got to admit that
they don't acknowledge that the
characters get older pretty much at all
or they over acknowledge it and they're
like yeah
I think it's over acknowledging more so
oh yeah or they're like they make cheesy
tongue-in-cheek jokes to how they used
to be younger but but when it comes to
like when it comes to the the moments
where they gotta get away with something
and something happens it's like they
always somehow miraculously make it
through even though they're way older
than they used to be in the in the
earlier ones and that's my gripe with it
whereas with Clint Eastwood films when
Clint Eastwood got older they were like
let's just acknowledge it's a new story
and he's an old man and he's gonna do
some oldies
instead of like trying to make him like
do young man [ __ ] as an old man yeah
well I don't but there's a thing though
that like there's this thing that
happens and like so I've experienced it
like when we make videos and we're like
hey let's make a follow-up or a sequel
or like working on dubstep guns too like
there's always this like uh there's this
what is it it's the
you get this impulse to turn back for
inspiration you know you're always like
going like well what made the first one
so cool how can we recreate that you
know that's like the first thing you
think about
um and like the more you make of these
things sometimes the more and more you
start just like like you become unable
to like just look ahead and make
something new and cool yeah because
you're so obsessed with trying to just
recreate past success and like that that
was like the problem with a lot of yeah
like just all sequels that we've ever
made have kind of that issue and and
generally do they do as well as the
first one like I mean other than the
Boston Dynamics video uh like generally
no yeah I was about to say that like I
feel like we don't really ever do
sequels we do spiritual successors yeah
yeah but like with these in yeah like
this happens with all these movies like
The Matrix and Star Wars and Indiana
Jones and stuff yeah they stop like like
the goals never seems to not ever be
like hey let's make something that's
like fun and new and cool using the same
characters but instead just like look
back and like you're basically just
doing a a remake but with the same cast
what did you guys think Star Wars 7 is
literally a remake yeah of Star Wars for
Hope yeah I know yeah we we don't need a
that's the Paradigm example I'm just
yeah yeah have you guys all seen top gun
Maverick oh yeah because I feel like
that's a huge exception to this rule
where it's there's two it's better than
the original oh yeah it's so much better
it's like it's either my first or second
favorite movie of this entire year yeah
so much better that and Blade Runner
it's the first Blade Runner 2049 yeah
Blade Runner is like you've watched it
and you're not yeah same with Top Gun
you're never at any point are you
feeling like you're just watching like a
slightly more polished version of the
older movie you know it's like you
you're getting something new it's a
completely new movie yeah yeah you know
you know what top gun Maverick is though
I saw one of those YouTube videos about
this I don't know the YouTubers like a
simplified story like condensed top gun
Maverick is just the trench run from a
new hope that's the whole movie we gotta
fly through these mountains we gotta
shoot a bomb into a hole and get away
imagine Luke trained a lot harder yeah
but
and it's so good
though because that's the best part of
it I never tried to like do
see with the story never tried to like
like make any cool twist or anything
it's just like
you think that top gun Maverick is
better than Top Gun yes without a doubt
as in the way that Terminator 2 is
undoubtedly better than the original
Terminator I don't really have a big
opinion on that but I feel like there's
I think the degrees of separation are
different in those two references but
overall I would agree with those things
it was good I didn't think it was better
than the original though the first Top
Gun movie is Jenna's favorite movie my
wife and pretty good because of that I
have been subjected to watching that
movie multiple times really so I've seen
good idea good times at this point
what's your favorite part when Goose
dies
Jesus no not really uh I don't know the
Jets cool
um I don't know it's just there's a
degree of like
boringness to it now at this point maybe
it's just because I've seen it so many
times but the second movie just felt so
fresh and everything about it just it
felt it just worked so well like every
thing it was trying to do it did in a
very good way yeah
I'm not saying it's I'm not saying it's
a bad movie at all I thought it was a
very good movie I thought it was a very
good movie I just didn't think it was
better than the original one well let me
put it this way I enjoyed it a hell of a
lot more than the original oh well
that's probably because you you don't
like the original
maybe you need to do something
I'm going to take this out at the
Christmas party I'm gonna ask her more
about it that movie's just enough though
like yeah I was reading this whole silly
thing like I don't I I I somehow fall
for this these click bait articles we're
like yeah
develop a new camera system to film top
gun Maverick and I'm like reading it's
like oh this is actually super crazy yes
like they're like oh yeah we want to get
those like dope GoPro angles that you
see but we want like nice cameras to
film it yeah so they like took apart a
Sony camera and we're like shove it in
the car no but they had to do that and
then they had to have the whole thing
like safety rated and stuff because it
had to be like flight worthy yeah so it
had to go through a similar process to
like how everything on the jet goes on
when it comes to like so like the
tolerances and the safety ratings and
how strong your safety can handle all
the G's and stuff and they had to like
test it for you know that was like the
first thing I was testing yeah it's
insane looks like that's pretty dope
like when we we're sitting here like
taping cameras to [ __ ] you know you know
we're like we gotta get a shot with this
car is like dude let's just tape the
[ __ ] on that yeah bro
[Laughter]
let's pull a quick barrel roll and the
camera just dislodges and flies around
the cockpit yeah these are like oh
someone in the government has to approve
our camera rig yeah
we'll also get the whole thing where
it's like they did shoot
oh we had the real actor there they were
actually pulling Real G's and all that
stuff and they're having to
you know they had moments that like all
right and then you're supposed to look
up to the left and be alarmed but it's
up to you to decide when that is and all
that stuff and people like yeah they
didn't have any effects in the movie
it's like hold up
that's not what they're saying either
yeah they shot a lot of practical stuff
but then everything was augmented like
most of those shots even when they're
filmed it's like
there are no Jets just off the wing you
know like those are added in and a lot
of the times the backgrounds were
completely replaced too yeah yeah
there's like 2 000 shots 2000 VFX shots
or something like that you mean the
pilots didn't actually go in there drop
that bomb and then pull that g to get
out of there I mean they did do a lot of
those maneuvers
but obviously not in freaking uh
nameless country Siberia that they were
not under the nameless
have you guys played the new Modern
Warfare game the one that came out like
three days ago is it a modernist country
Siberia no no well I'm just saying like
so the first Modern Warfare game and
this this latest one that came up
some of the coolest single player
campaigns I've ever played are you
literally talking about the one that
came out like in the last week or two
yeah yeah yeah okay so Modern Warfare 2
came out and and like dude right off the
gate they're just like Iran's trying to
get nukes
[Laughter]
the name
brand shirt yeah they they do I guess so
yeah let's just yeah and they're like oh
yeah the cartel's helping them now it's
like oh [ __ ] there we go we're in Mexico
it's like not like you know whatever
Mexican or something I don't know you
know they're not like making up similar
names they're just like they're just
going hard it's like I mean I mean
that's obviously what the series is
known for but I'm just like become so
used to like films trying to like
neutralize like real words cutting all
the edges off of everything and turn
them into these imaginary situations
which is exactly what they did in Top
Gun Maverick it's like literally like
the country they're they're invading and
fighting against or whatever like
there's no actual nationality ever
mentioned enemy which and in military
speak it like it works it's like I
thought it totally worked yeah so you're
not concerned with who you're bombing
it's like it's your job to kill them
exactly in the context of that movie I
actually really appreciated that but it
was totally Russia
as soon as they pull up and it's snowy
I'm like guys I see what you guys are
doing yeah yeah something like that yeah
anyway but it's great you should play it
so it's it's Modern Warfare 2 2. yeah
because there's Modern Warfare 2 that
came out like
15 years ago yeah so look if you're
confused by this then don't don't just
skip it if you can't if you can't
conceive that they remade it it's the
last rebooted it but is it a reboot or
is it a brand new game original story
it's it's original it's new it's it's
okay so it's a new campaign
it's not remastered it's like it's it's
they're just calling they just were like
look we want to just it's simple for
things we're just starting back at
Modern Warfare yeah as many copies as
possible is it the same startup that
goes no but that's the fun thing it is
the same characters as the original
Modern Warfare it's the same characters
because they killed off a bunch of them
in like the SEC Modern Warfare 2 from
yeah before that too no no no no
they haven't died yet this is like
alternate universe no just imagine that
like okay what is this game imagine
you're making Star Wars and you just you
killed the emperor you know in your like
the last year
you're talking about like we should make
more Star Wars movies and then you're
like but ah dude that Emperor character
but that's what they did okay that was
actually a joke I was setting up a joke
there they did that poorly
somehow a ghost has returned imagine
that but then they just but they start
the storyline from like Day Zero instead
of like trying to like weave it back in
that's cool instead of like you know
sweet though okay this one is Modern
Warfare called this one is Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare Roman numeral two
uh maybe that could be well regardless
okay I'm still trying to figure out what
the distinction is between they
literally use the exact same title yeah
but that's okay it's okay because it's a
new game and if you've been playing the
modern warfare games you won't be
confused
The Single part for the first one is
like the best ever
but uh I imagine Modern Warfare one
single player more than two because that
was the one where he got the ghillie
suit and you're like oh the sniper
missions
yeah it's cool
I gotta get to the bottom of this is
this a remix it's just like look that
was a cool cast of characters and their
stories some of them died off whatever
and then they're just like you know
screw that let's just make more cool
stuff with that who cares I don't think
I've played a Call of Duty game in like
eight or ten years dude I used to [ __ ]
on Call of Duty once Call of Duty 3 came
out you know or whatever Modern Warfare
3 or once they used to love playing them
once the once they fell off the deep end
you know and I was like I do Call of
Duty socks and then they reboot it it's
like this is the best playing a nice
polished game yeah like a triple A game
it's like God what a great experience
did I get it on my PS5 like it's not
some [ __ ] Early Access ten dollars
you're like
you're like oh you got to play the
hottest game it's this random cartoon
yanking out and when you jump around or
whatever it's like yeah
like dude I want like AAA voice acting
insane character design I want blur
Studios to do all the cinematics yeah
it's like I want I want all of it
is there a Zombies mode
yeah I don't know probably oh dude so
much time in freaking cod zombies that's
so good yeah I dropped out before that
once cod zombies was the thing
yeah I would already hit my Cog fatigue
by that point so I was just like
whatever World at War not too zombies
Good Times
oh man
wow
anyways
sweet it's so sick
Modern Warfare to the reboot Modern
Warfare III
[Laughter]
he's talking about two games
wait for two came out a long time ago
like you don't have to make fun of me
it's just very this is very
unconventional for a video game to not
at least call it something new
they do this with movies but those
movies are literally reboots of The
Originals they should have done this and
then you can and then there's a
reference point you can say is it is it
True Grit from 1957 or is it True Grit
from 2009 which one is it or whatever
they are yeah you know and then you have
a year where you can reference it so
it's but you can't I don't know if that
lectures
I guess that that is it that is it yeah
versus Modern Warfare 2 2009. I honestly
I think Star Wars should start from
episode one again
I want to see Star Wars episode one
coming out in 2025
new story yeah
if Disney has their way that's exactly
what's gonna happen they're like Qui-Gon
Jinn was a great character it was
honestly a mistake to kill him in the
first episode yeah you know what the
story's about him now yeah Just Go With
It Just go with it it's an alternate guy
episode two although I mean Star Wars I
have been really enjoying Andor have you
guys checked that out good I I kept
hearing good things and I was like I'm
so busy I haven't finally I got around I
was like all right fine I'll check out
this and or I was so burned by Obi-Wan
yeah and
I've been to the first two episodes in
one go and I'm I'm now like five or six
episodes deep and the show is incredible
it keeps getting better yeah it ramps up
so well like it just it yeah it's so
good well it's truly a testament on
Disney's behalf that they were able to
get you guys to watch one more Star Wars
show I know after all they've done to us
and the only reason why it is because
everyone kept raving about it I was done
after Obi-Wan I was pissed dude
guys I can't wait for Star Wars one 2025
to come out I know I'm just gonna be
great I want the Star Wars one
parentheses 2025 episode one let's go
back let's fix all the wrongs let's make
it better
fix all the wrongs
dude right on episode one it's great
it's like what you mean the movie from
1999 it's like no Star Wars episode one
from 2025. no silly no the new one the
new one wait there's a new one people
why didn't they give us
Qui-Gon Jin lives
wait is it prequel it's like no it's not
a prequel anymore it's the beginning of
this new like triple trilogy but it has
the same character they're doing it in
order this time
50 years later
dude get get ready Disney plus come on
let's do this episode one the series
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it hurts but it's so accurate
and they just smelled on the volume they
just may
and then they'll go well this is an
official Star Wars can and this is just
it's separate Canon it's alternate Canon
they'll come up with some other name for
it for your own enjoyment
oh yeah oh man well that's what we're
doing around here just solving the
world's problems all right
um I'm very excited for uh to see your
Nerfs Ren and also to see to see the uh
anime rock paper scissors video come
together I feel like it's finally we're
getting able to apply some of these
tools in a truly original creative way
instead of just kind of hey look at the
potential of this yeah I mean other than
the fact that you know we're stealing
Decades of artists Styles and work and
Transformers well yeah but I mean that's
that's been the case look that's been
the case throughout our throughout the
history of Art and I know it's like
yourself God forbid you look at a
painting and then want to draw one like
that for yourself yeah right yeah
God for a minute I watched The Matrix
when I was a young lad and then I've
forever tried to do slow motion bullets
no there ain't nothing wrong with that
uh something that I I've been really
wanting to do but haven't yet is you
know how like a lot of the new games
have like cinematic mode or sorry not
cinematic mode photo mode
or like it pauses the game and you can
get rid of the entire life yeah I want
to start making Nerfs for my games
well yeah yeah like literally just like
your own screen the camera around
sometimes the same way I would normally
for a regular Nerf process that through
the web and get a thing out of it and
then I can get my own camera moves in
there if I've got like a costume or
something like I'm cosplaying as a
character from say Horizon forbidden
West and I'm able to get us really sweet
realistic looking location that I can
then camera track to real footage of a
person wearing a costume on a green
screen like
I think there's something to be said for
that yeah you remember do you remember
when Concepts like this were referred to
as mixed media it's the ultimate phone
app sorry what did you say do you
remember when Concepts like that were
referred to as mixed media media and New
Media
do you remember that that time yeah now
it's just media again yeah
[Laughter]
yeah right it's uh because there's AR
there's XR there's VR and so they just
refer to all of it as Mr Mr now it's all
just Mr which will soon just because
I'm not sure
they all come out with different names
for it maybe XR is the mixed reality
thing and they're just they don't know
how to spell yeah it's cooler if it's
in reality yeah
it does make it sound futuristic if you
put an X in front of it guys all right
let's place our bets right here 10 bucks
um when does the first phone app come
out that allows you
to basically film someone have the
footage 3D tracked have the subject
keyed that you're filming and then also
allows you to select from an array of
Nerfs for the environment in which
they're in basically effectively doing
what all like Zoom meetings and Google
you know like you know the auto key but
now it's in your phone and the camera's
also moving in that environment how how
long until we see that I mean that's
basically just lumobile with a keying
thing right I mean yeah and a lot of
those things are are things right now uh
it's just the hardware is not good
enough to do that fast enough yet like
our iPhones are already good enough to
do live segmentation basically green
screening without a green screen and it
removes a subject and puts you know
something behind them I can already do
that with like freaking polycam right
now yeah also if you guys
2024 another two phones but have you
seen this thing on the phones where you
just you just press this yeah and now
you have an element yeah you've seen
that like on the new phones you you have
a photo Sam's referring to basically on
the iPhone what if you just like hold
down
automatically crop that person out we're
talking like magic masks I'm pretty sure
drag that down and put it in like a text
message the new iPhone model has a thing
where you basically just new iOS it's
not even the new iPhone sorry the new
iOS that's what I meant to say I don't
and I didn't Sarah accidentally did it
the other day she was like she
accidentally tapped the picture and it
like selected the care like the subject
and it was like whoa whoa it it just did
Magic mask on the person I'm pretty sure
it's it's it's it's probably like an AI
model that is integrated because it's
object recognition you know iPhones
these days have an entire like half of
the processor dedicated to AI based
tests yeah that's right that's what I'm
saying so like
I I can totally imagine in a year or two
it's like all right sweet well we
already have the accelerometers we have
Nerfs all we need to do is find a way to
just make them more optimized so you can
just load one up on a phone and then
just auto key someone I'd say there's
less than two years dude yeah I'm
guessing the next thing they have to do
is like real time it's basically now you
can film anyone on your phone and
pretend like you're in any location it's
like eight months eight months literally
I can do that right now
what do you what do you say eight months
eight months eight months so that puts
us in we'll call it this December so
that puts us in July
okay yeah I can see it Ren
it's certainly possible within the year
absolutely it's just a matter of like
who's gonna do it
might do it polycam might do it
polycam's already got like that sort of
AR feature set but we need to
introducing Nerfs as well kind of yeah
yeah kind of they've now allowed you to
download full data sets including like
the position data for each camera pose
uh to run through a different program
called Nerf Studio which is sick I
haven't tried it yet yeah I'm guessing
March of 24.
all right I was gonna say November of
24.
November two full years okay
is this gonna require someone to be able
to ten bucks on the line real-time
render of a Nerf though Radiance 10. we
will send it to you via comment in our
video we'll comment to you and say
you've won a prize DM us directly oh God
please don't respond to those oh my God
guys I'm joking if you see it Corridor
crew or Corridor cast or Corridor
Digital respond to you and request a DM
from you in one of our YouTube videos
that is Spam we get emails every day of
people saying hey did you guys DM me oh
yeah housekeeping housekeeping yeah uh
we're not doing giveaways in the
comments we never do giveaways in the
comments okay we never do giveaways
anyway
no we've done that we've done a few and
if we do them in the future it will it
will not be through just telling you in
the comments you've won a prize okay
yeah I'm just gonna say that right here
and now okay
what if we did though what if we did
just uh what if it's a really good prize
too that would be really advising for
shipping yeah but you still have to pay
us for shipping and it would further
perpetuate the the that's the scam yeah
CS5 and then they email them and then
they're like oh yes pay us 120 for
shipping of the PS5 it's like okay
I I really hope no one's actually had to
pay anyone that that would be sad
uh well we got off on a tangent on that
one I was just saying ten dollars ten
doll hairs to the winner
all right cool all right let's do it
yeah I mean it's all happening so fast
do you think it'll be a new app or do
you think it's gonna be an existing app
I can't possibly imagine what new apps
will come into existence within the next
year I think I think it'll be a tick
tock update
yeah honestly yeah very real possibility
definitely not Instagram they're
dragging their feet on everything yeah
all right well thanks for watching
everyone all right it's gonna help us
and thanks for watching and uh wow it's
good chatting with you guys I can't wait
to see what uh dystopian AI Futures we
get into next time next time
next week that's that's next week
next week we talk about Twitter
okay I'm out just kidding see you all
right three two one ah oh wait we
haven't had the music yet honestly it's
my best we're fading out here right yeah
cool just just unfollow Elon Musk
it like Twitter's fine it's just just
don't follow him and Kanye West it
doesn't matter like then then you're
fine yeah there's nothing to be mad
about anymore if Twitter just suddenly
shuts down one day oh well
oh my God Twitter
I'm just saying